these Japanese mechanics otherwise known
as snow monkeys are frolicking in the
waters of this primate sanctuary in
Texas so what are Pickford snow monkeys
the only primates other than humans that
can survive extreme cold doing here in
Texas
well a small group of these playful
creatures once angered the merchants of
kyoto japan by raiding their stores they
needed to be relocated or they'd be
killed the only place to attack then was
a remote corner of good old Texas and
this sanctuary was built for them there
so now instead of warming up and hot
volcanic Japanese Springs these snow
monkeys and their offspring use water to
cool off and have fun
something macaque seemed to know how to
do wherever they are next time you get
all wrapped up and how serious the world
is think of these monkeys then go jump
in a lake